first of all did some alkyl Rifkin do
you think make the right decision today
yes I think he did but I think it's very
sad he's had a very distinguished public
career as as Jack Straw devoted four
decades of his life to public service
and I think it's sad that a life of
public service and because of brouhaha
you think it's sad but was it the right
call oh yes it was right he was absolute
dude but I feel sad and sympathetic to
him on a personal level that he is a
good man who's worked very hard for his
country who made an error of judgment
towards the latter part of his career
and I think that something one should
have human sympathy for Lisa Nandi
Michael Rifkin Jack Straw as well both
making the decision to stand down as MPs
what's your view should politicians step
down before they've been proved to have
broken any rules
well I think in jackstraws case he was
already something down at the next
election and I would echo part of what
Jacob said is that I think it's
absolutely right that Jack in particular
had referred himself to the independent
watchdog for parliamentary standards is
having the case investigated and is no
longer part of the parliamentary Labour
Party well that happens I think that's
absolutely right because there has to be
a thorough independent investigation but
there's a bigger question here I think
about members of parliament having
second jobs paid directorships and
consultancies and tomorrow in the House
of Commons we've got a vote to try to
stop that from happening
I think in this day and age most people
understand that we're human and that we
make mistakes and are very sympathetic
to that but aren't sympathetic to the
idea that when they send us the
Parliament to do a job in the public
interest with our full time and
attention that there are a number of MPs
of all parties who are taking money from
private interests and that's something
that we're determined to stamp out okay
well I got a quick response from Jacob
Riis mob on that issue do you want
entirely professional politicians who
know nothing other than politics do
nothing other than politics what do you
want people to bring business experience
into the House of Commons and make a
contribution from what they know in
business I think it's very important to
have members of parliament with outside
interests and there are certainly time
to do it because ministers have a sec
job for which they get paid beyond being
parliamentarians and unless you won't
have the American system where you have
the ministers entirely separate from
Parliament you have to have a parliament
that allows for ministers to do their
second job well I'm not gonna get drawn
into another debate about whether or not
MP should have other jobs for now but at
least Andy let's broaden out a little
bit further do you think the politician
should have higher standards than the
rest of us and I don't think that the
public expects us to have higher
standards in fact I think it quite sadly
the public at the moment expects that we
have lowest standards but I think they'd
like to see that because we have really
responsible jobs the decisions that we
make affect millions of people and I do
think there's a big distinction between
having outside experience having say run
a Sixth Form College for many years
before you come into Parliament and
taking money from private say health
care companies while you're a member of
parliament for a consultancy it's really
hard to see as a member of the public
how you can have confidence in the
decisions that we're making if we have
those outside interests and that's why
it's really important that we are not
just sticking to the rules as they are
but actually making sure that the rules
are fit for purpose as well and how much
of a measure so that sent out to the
public politicians need to play by the
rules or the public why should the
public absolutely and you shouldn't have
paid lobbyists it is quite wrong from
them as opponent take money to lobby it
is not wrong for them to be barristers
or doctors or in my case an investment
manager which has no conflict with what
you're doing in the House of Commons and
is not a question of using your
influence in terms of your business but
influence peddling is definitely wrong
and finally Lisa that nandi defeat the
public are actually more forgiving than
we think on these issues I think the
public are very forgiving of the fact
that we're human beings and we make
mistakes you know there were a couple of
cases recently there was Maria Miller
the culture secretary who resigned over
expenses after a long protracted
drawn-out public Rauh but there was also
a case of another Conservative MP one of
her colleagues Charlotte Lesley who made
a mistake on her expenses came to the
houses of parliament and said that she
was sorry I think the public really
understands that we are just human
beings and we
mistakes what they don't understand is
when they look at a handful of people in
Parliament who think that it's okay to
play by different rules than the rest of
us and that's why we're having this vote
tomorrow because we're determined to
change it okay well no doubt this debate
will run belong there listen Andy and
take a reason well thanks very much
indeed thank you